hopefully hopefully I'm working on a
different level than yourselves what I'm
doing is we all know that the shape of
the will
be an arched
back but a lot of you are not getting to
that stage so as with I was saying with
Danny ear when I said look he wasn't
letting Scott make his full movement and
then turning he was ending it where he
thought it should be you're doing same
with the as this see Jenn is s a little
bit bent but that's about all W into the
floor so we all know that we all know
that this is the arch of what really
should be you should do most of us after
you get to
about you should definitely know so I'm
looking to
maximize the benefits healthwise as well
as get
I'm trying to get
here so then see Jenny I fall down I
don't have to do any more
work cuz unless you can sort of like do
a back flip or something get out there
but at least it maximizes it right so
it's this
maximization and then if I want to be a
little bit harder put with you guys or
whatever you know I can add that but
then that makes me de agress but you you
need a some Buzz out
like long you don't break
people so she runs out of her own
energy I know
it's you're it's like trying to go up
against a mountain
it but if you let them run a little bit
further but you've got to get that shape
in them so once you get that that shape
you see you're nearly into basic you're
nearly into the basic but you you get
that shape and then you dropping them
down let's just try that else you're
never going to make